deux équipes et un même objectif
survivre dans ce championnat de d2 deux
districts il percevait la réserve de
versailles ce dimanche 9 février après
une première période équilibrée ce sont
finalement les versaillais qui arrivent
à faire la différence
1 à 0 ce sera le score à la pause un
résultat ces versements les villes
provient la première on a notre but
refusé injustement jeu nous aura permis
au moins de garder la distance vitres
refuser l'équipe n'est sorti du match
mais après voilà on n'a pas manqué en
amont a manqué d'occasions dans mon cas
de volonté et le vent qui nous a
beaucoup gênés car gêner les deux
équipes au retour des vestiaires sous
une pluie battante et le vent les deux
équipes ont du mal à produire leurs
meilleures partitions versailles
réalisera tout de même le break score
final à 2 à 0
satisfaction des trois points après le
travail sur le terrain a été compliquée
avec les conditions météo un vent pas
possible maintenant sa satisfaction des
trois points on est tellement mal placé
dans le classement par rapport au projet
de chemin qu'on avait prévu que les
trois points c'est le plus important
au classement l'équipe 3 de versailles
toujours 11e et revient à hauteur des
premier non relégable
de son côté ville promet toujours bon
dernier avec une seule victoire depuis
le début de la saison ils ont pris un
petit coup
maintenant il faut pas lâcher il ya
encore des matches à jouer la saison est
encore long on n'est jamais n'est jamais
à l'abri d'un miracle pour continuer à
croire au miracle villes pro se
déplacera sur le terrain de montesson le
dimanche 1er mars